existen dos tipos de dispositivos
intrauterinos
diu hormonal
y dio de cobre
para evitar el embarazo el médico coloca
un diu dentro del útero de la mujer con
el hilo colgando dentro de la vagina
ambos tipos de diu hacen que el
endometrio se inflamen levemente lo que
libera células inmunes y sustancias
químicas que matan los espermatozoides
y los diu hormonales contienen un tipo
sintético de progesterona denominado
levonorgestrel
el levonorgestrel
principalmente evita un embarazo es
pesando la mucosidad dentro del cuello
uterino lo que evita que los
espermatozoides entren en el útero
también evita el engrosamiento del
endometrio de manera que es menos
probable que reciba un óvulo fecundado